yes Lord and Savior Potter PI has
descended upon this earth to give his
opinion about pointless stupid [ __ ]
we're back I know you're in quite a
pickle right now I know you're wondering
would haha serious would you rather see
how or what created civilization or see
how or what end civilization I could not
give a [ __ ] about either Jesus Christ
next question live in the time of the
ancient Roman / Greeks or live in the
dark ages
what is Dark Ages sorry I don't I'm not
stupid I just don't know what that is in
English like medieval ages that's
actually really hard cuz the Greeks they
were like that's like the top of
humanity that's when we actually you
starting to like for [ __ ] and didn't
wash stupid [ __ ] PewDiePie Betty but
Dark Ages everyone thing is bad cuz like
people people die from sickness and all
kinds of horrible [ __ ] back then at
least you know what you killed some
people
and they were it was a good time some
what would you rather be s you are now
or have hundred million dollars but have
a 5% chance of instant damn 5 percent
that's pretty low that's pretty [ __ ]
low I'll roll the dice
Oh Oh bird poo deploy you have a
gazillion billion dollars why would you
need more come on five percent chance
I'll take it you take it - come on look
look me in the eyes and say you wouldn't
take it would you take it
would you rather snow for the rest of
your life or rain for the rest of your
life you mean have snow for the rest of
your life or am i snow for the rest of
my life or am i rain for the rest snow
obviously are you [ __ ] what what no
need to shovel rain have you heard of
[ __ ] flooding [ __ ] watch your
parents be murdered in front of you or
murder the parents of another family in
front of their children oh I like this
this is good okay I mean they're both
great they're both so good like you
can't really loot lose it's just which
one is better
um I like the idea of that one so I'll
go with that one would you rather burn
to death or drown if anyone anyone picks
burn to death it burned to death should
be 0%
let's hurry this idiots would you rather
have stretchable legs or have
stretchable arms oh this is very
important I'd go with stretchable legs
so that I could have my legs as a
blanket or a scarf when I'm out walking
what if you were a pirate would you
rather have a pet monkey or have a
talking parrot what what is wrong with
you
watch the Big Bang Theory or watch the
up the office easy what I'm shocked
hahaha I [ __ ] hate Big Bang Theory
they don't know anything about true
physics
candolyn theory - laugh track reset the
board must be humbling to suck on so
many different levels this is awkward
thing I've ever seen
wait we need to get a laugh track on
this channel can we get that no pute I'm
really rather busy sorry
no goddamnit if you were a dog would you
rather be a stray on the street or have
bad owners stray on the street Spratt
I'm from the hood baby would you rather
have a one-night stand or have friends
with benefits
Oh
oh oh hey high five high five for that
one would you rather sole yourself and
have nobody know or not sole yourself
but everyone thinks you did
I don't care people think I saw myself
I'm not 12 okay well apparently everyone
doing this quizzes would you rather eat
a cup of baking soda and then do a shot
of vinegar or eat a pack of mentos and
then chug Diet Coke I've done that it's
not so bad it's like what would you
rather eat Mentos and Diet Coke or
baking soda and vinegar mmm I don't know
would you rather know when you will die
or know how you will die oh I want to
hear you guys opinion on this one I'd be
okay knowing how I will die cuz then
that way I can try and prevent it right
like if I die from a heart attack I'll
try and have a heart donor ready
I don't what alright well that was this
episode I hope you enjoyed it uh let me
know your opinion about the answers did
I do right - I do do right or wrong and
that's it for now leave a like if you
enjoyed it then as always stay awesome
what if everyone you attract you get
attracted to are attracted to you
alright
I can dig that but you [ __ ] yourself
every time you kiss someone for the
first time